why is it that the uk is facing what
some would call a supply crisis
certainly with energy prices being
really high the short answer is i'm
afraid there is no single short answer
but what we can do is look at some of
the data some of that data is really
striking this shows you gas prices so
it's wholesale gas prices that your
supplier might uh pay and look for most
of the past few years because we're
going back a few years here back to 2016
they've been around that kind of range
in the last few months just look at
what's happened wow it's gone up so fast
actually the biggest increase we have
really ever seen up to 178 pounds per
thumb in short it's the highest uh it's
been and as a result of that we're
seeing electricity prices uh rising very
sharply as well this is electricity
price obviously you've got different
forms of generation as we'll see in a
moment some people have been asking is
it just the uk facing this or are other
countries in europe facing similar
problems as well well look at this you
can see we've got a few other european
countries and you can see those lines
are going up they've gone up an awful
lot but they're not quite as high as
that black line which is the uk why is
it that the uk in particular is facing
high prices well it's a range of
different factors one of them is because
of the kinds of
sources we rely on for our power so this
is just showing you where we get our
electricity from uh in the uk you can
see there's wind power there are kind of
fossil fuels so coal and gas power that
used to be a lot is less now than it was
wind power is going up and up uh but
then you've got other for instance
nuclear and the striking thing to note
here is look at wind it was going up and
up and up but just in this last autumn
what we're looking at is each autumn of
each year basically in the latest autumn
it's gone down a fair bit so we've had
less wind power coming in and as a
result of that you know that's part of
the reason why prices are slightly
higher like i say it's not everything
there's all sorts of factors going on at
the same time which are pushing up gas
prices around europe but that's one of
the issues in the uk and when you look
at what's happened to wind speeds in the
uk over the past 20 years that's your
historic range through the year look at
what's happened in 2021 they've really
been quite low and that's just going up
to july we're expecting quite low
numbers for august and september as well
so low wind some issues with high gas
prices it's all added up to what a lot
of people are calling the supply crisis